またまた唐突なようでありますけれども、
極めて大きな影響力を持つ統治者、
政治家でありますけども、理想像に関して
古代ギリシャの哲学者でありますけども、
プラトンが非常に興味深い見解を示しているんですね。
プラトンというとこういう話が出てくるんですけれども、
河野さんは学術的って言葉がありますけども、これ、
英語でAcademicっていいますけども、
いろんなところに学校があって、ここが
Academyとかっていうふうにいわれますけれども、
この言葉の語源っていうのはご存じですかね。
それこそプラトンのアカデメイアというのから
きてるというの習ったような気がしますね。
そうなんです。よくご存じですね。
プラトンは紀元前4世紀にアテネ、アテナイですけども、
郊外に森があったんですが、
その森がアカデミアというふうに
呼ばれてたんですけども、そこの森に学校を作ります。
この学校、ローマ時代に閉校に、
無理やり閉じさせられるんですけども、
それまで約1000年間ぐらい続いた学校なんですね。
ある意味で世界で最も早くできあがった、
最も長く続いた高等教育機関の一つだと
思うんですけれども、ここでどんな
教育が行われたかっていうのはご存じですか。
具体的なところは全くわからないんですが。
本当にそれがそのとおり
行われていたかどうかっていうの、
よくわからないんですけども、例えば
18歳で入学をすると。その入学のときには
幾何学のちゃんとマスターしてなければいけないと。
あるいは、詩の書き方っていうのを
マスターしなきゃいけない＊＊＊。
18歳から30歳ぐらいまで、プラトンは数学を
非常に重視してましたんで数学だけをやると。
30歳から35歳ぐらいまで議論の仕方を学ぶと。
35歳になって、やっと学校を出る。学校を出て
いろんな地域に出かけていって世界を見るんですね。
35歳で。
はい。それで、50歳、ギリシャ時代の50歳ですから
本当にかなりのお年寄りになってはじめて
自分が統治すべきポリス、都市国家に帰ってこいと、
こういう。それが本当に
そういうふうに行われたかどうか、
私は専門家でないんで少々わかりませんけども、
プラトンの著作の中にはそういったようなことが
書かれているわけですね。この学校っていうのは、
政治をつかさどるものっていうのが
ものごとの本質を見極める、プラトンによるところの
哲学をちゃんと極めて、それでものを
考えることができる哲人としてあらなければならないと。
だから、哲学的な思考ができるようなカリキュラム、
そういうものが設定されて、
その運営をされていたわけですね。
プラトンは国家の政治的な支配者というのは
人間社会の現実的な価値の世界を超越して、
哲学的な価値を理解できねばならないと。
ですから、哲人というふうにいわれますけれども、
哲学者としての能力が不可欠であるというふうに
彼は考えていたわけです。こういって、
そういう哲人となった統治者のことを彼は哲人王、
Philosopher kingというふうに呼んだわけですね。
じゃあ、ちょっと読んでみますけれども、
国家の正義も個々人の正義も、
ただ哲学からこそこれを見極めることができると。
したがって、正しい意味で、かつ真実に
哲学している人たちが国の政治的支配の地位につくか、
それとも、現に国々において権力を持っている人たちが
何らかの神の配分に恵まれて哲学するようになるかの
どちらかが実現されない限り、人類が
災いから免れることはないであろうと、
こういうふうに言っているわけです。
河野さん、どうでしょう。古代ギリシャのポリス、
都市国家を統治をしていた王たちと
21世紀の技術者とを比べてみると、どちらのほうが
大きな影響力というのを持つと思いますか。
単純な比較はもちろんできないと思うんですが、
政治的な文脈に注目すれば、統治者のほうが
強い影響力を持つとはいえますが、その枠をはずすと
科学技術が進展していくと
なかなかわからなくなってくるかなというふうに。
私は21世紀の技術者のほうがはるかに
大きな影響力を持つんじゃないかなと思います。
ビル・ジョイが言うように、人類を滅亡させることも
可能なわけですよね。その一方で、
ホンダの技術者の人たちのように子どもたちに
青い空を残す。そういうこともできるわけです。
また、今回見たように、福島第一原子力発電所の
所長であった吉田さんのように
日本が放射能に汚染されて人が住めなくなる、
そういう地域と、それより北の部分、そして
それより南の部分と。そういうふうに
3分割されるっていうのを防ぐっていうことも
1人の技術者ができたわけですね。
そういった影響力を持っている一方で、
その影響力に、ある意味見合っているような教育とか、
あるいは社会的な地位が用意されているとは
考えにくいわけですよね。
そうなんですね。近代科学というのは、ある意味、
すべての社会的あるいは文化的、
そういう政治的な価値を切り捨てて事実命題、
どんどん哲学的な言葉になってしまいますけれども、
事実命題のみを扱うことによって
17世紀に成立をしたと考えられます。そのあと、
急速な発展を続けてきたわけでありますけども、
その過程で倫理的な問い、
つまり行為の善悪でありますとか、なすべき行為は
いったい何なのか。こういった言明、これは
当為命題というふうにいいますけれども、
これを排除し続けてきたわけですね。
また、科学的に扱うことが困難だと考えられた、
よく生きること、well-beingでありますけれども、
これについての検討っていうのも、
ある意味避けてきた、
できなかったと言うべきなのかもしれませんけれども。
確かに20世紀後半の技術者育成のための
システムを考えてみると、急速に発展している
科学技術の担い手を育成するために
すぐにできあがった科学技術の成果を使って
目の前にある問題をいかに解くか、
つまりHowというところですか、
そういった知識を伝授することに追われてきたように
見られるというふうに思いますね。
いかに知るかというか、いかに作るかを教えてきた、
教えようとしてきたということだと思うんですが、
ただ、この科目でも検討してきたように、
科学技術が巨大な影響力を持つように
なってきたわけですから、何を知るべきか、
何を作るべきか、そういったことを考える
教育というのも必要かなというふうに思いますね。
特に新しい時代において科学技術と社会が
これまでと違ったかたちの関係を
持つわけでありますから、じゃあ、われわれが
目指すべき社会とはいったい何なのか。
あるいは社会のwell-beingに貢献するために、
いったい技術者は何に取り組めばいいのかと。
こういった、ある意味、技術の実践に関しての
WhatとWhyですね。こういう問題を自ら見いだして
自律的に判断できる能力。こういう能力を持った
技術者を育成していくのが新しい時代における
技術者教育であるというふうに私は考えます。
そして、そういう教育が生み出す技術者は、
プラトンが統治者に求めていたような
資質と能力を持った技術の専門家、これは
こういうふうに言えるんじゃないかと思いますけども、
哲人技術者、Philosopher Engineerでなければ
ならないんじゃないかなあというふうに私は思います。
哲人王がよき都市国家を築いて治めるための政治を
実践することに努めたように、哲人技術者、
Philosopher Engineerは幸せな世界、
人々がよく生きることができる世界に貢献するために
努力をしなければいけない。そして、21世紀の
Philosopher Engineerを目指す技術者にとって、
技術者倫理っていうのは、何か倫理っていうのは
多くの人たちに周辺領域であると、
あるいは一般教養的なものであるとか、
付加的なものである、さらにはお飾り的なものであると、
こういうふうに言う人がいるかもしれませんけれども、
私はそうではないと思います。技術者というのは、
社会の福利のために科学的な知識と能力を使って
貢献する専門的な職業である。
これ、最初の講義のときに技術者の
定義をいたしましたけれども、
そういう技術者であるとするならば、
科学技術の価値だけではなくて、
それ以外の価値というのも（？）十分理解をして、
適切なバランスというのを取りながら
最適な行為というものを自ら設計して、それを
実行する能力。これが技術者倫理でありますけども、
こういう倫理、こういう能力っていうのは、
技術者の本質にかかわる
中核的な能力であるというふうに考えられます。
この比喩が正しいのかどうかわかりませんけども、
ソフトウエアに例えれば、倫理的な能力、
特に思考倫理的な能力っていうのは
オペレーティングシステムの
部分じゃないかと思うんですよね。いくら優れた
最先端のアプリケーションがあったとしても、
このオペレーティングシステムっていうのが
ちゃんとしていないと、ソフトウエア全体としては
ちゃんと機能しませんよね。ですから、
私はそういうふうに考えています。
さらに、繰り返しになりますけれども、
プラトンが作ったアカデミア。ここを卒業した
プラトンの最も優秀な弟子といわれています
アリストテレス。万学の祖といわれておりますけども、
彼は自分が行ったいろんな活動のすべてを
集約したうえで、人生の課題っていうものは
最も崇高なものを手に入れること＊＊＊。
その崇高なものがeudaimonia、well-beingであると、
よく生きることである、こういうことを
はっきりと述べているわけですね。
一人一人の技術者の方々が
Philosopher Engineerを目指して公衆の福利、
well-beingを最優先しながら社会の中で
社会のために日々の業務というものを行うことで、
意味のある、meaningfulな仕事ができると思います。
そして、習慣的にそれを行うことによって、
その技術者が持っている特性、
＊＊＊でありますけども、そして、
その品格が高まって、そして技術者自身の主観的な
幸福度も上がる。これは既に議論したとおりです。
この科目を履修した皆様には、ぜひ、公衆の福利、
well-beingに貢献をして、それを実現し、
自らも幸せな哲人技術者、Philosopher Engineerを
目指していただきたいと思います。
それがよく生きることにつながるわけですから。